all right we are going to be taking a
look today at the best defenses in the
National Football League
yeah the subject of the draft it's not
an Andrew Luck inspired draft and now we
continue our break from the Andrew Luck
talk we've done best offenses today's
best defense is Chris the as you know
and as anyone out there who's been
watching for the past couple of weeks
knows the coin toss it's done dominated
ring it's rigged so now the trivia
question is rigged right which team in
the NFL allowed the fewest yards in the
league last year
ooh done defense obviously offense there
Texas what do you got the more Ravens
was not convincing that was not
convincing you got it right
i--you'll a gave me the wrong answer
sound I was like damn no you got it
right can you change that sound I got it
right that's the right that's the red to
last the first one it sounds like we got
a text message that I need it but we
need a better you won sense yes you're
ready both are like Debbie Downer sounds
there come on we could do better than
that all right you get the first pick
boss yes right and it's I feel like you
I would say well that was too easy I pay
attention to stuff like that way too I
was just going through stats from last
year and looking at it so it was right
there I don't have it here in front of
me but I looked at it not long ago so
sorry that's poor planning on stats
that's stats fault right yes
yup screw you stats bad job by you all
right okay I'm going to the Chicago
Bears I know that Vic Fangio is not
there but I don't care this is still one
hell of a defense I got a go with them I
mean just some of the people they have
up front whether it's Eddie Goldman
Hakeem Hicks right huge size and the
interior D line oh yeah and then maybe
one of the best linebacking core is in
football when you get to Khalil Mac
Leonard Floyd roll Quan Smith a middle
linebacker
who's looked really good in the
preseason watch out for him and then you
get in the secondary and you got guys
like Kyle fuller who's one of the best
corners in the game safety place
top-notch guy pie makers like Eddie
Jackson and I think Chuck Pagano is a
hell of a defensive coach I do not think
it will be a huge drop or any drop at
all from what we saw in Vic Fangio I
still think the Bears the cream of the
crop in my in my eyes yeah I think
that's an obvious first pick
because of how good they were last year
even with the change in defensive
coordinators this bears defense is still
going to be very good the question is
can the offense perform at a higher
level to allow both sides to come
together enough it's always both sides
that come together that determined how
good a team is and you know as the
saying goes it's the best defense is a
good offense right Bo look I'm not gonna
go quite that far
now but in Jacksonville if the offense
is better the defense is gonna be better
and I'm gonna take the Jaguars just top
to bottom everywhere you look everywhere
you turn there are star players and I am
so excited about the arrival of Josh al
and the seventh overall pick in the
draft for the second straight year there
was a Josh Allen as the seventh overall
pick in the draft although this one
doesn't play quarterback
he's the defensive lineman yeah the
Giants on cap when they took Daniel
Jones he was all over the place against
the Dolphins in that preseason game
earlier this month and she's got the
potential to be great and they've got
guys like Myles Jack and they've got
Jalen Ramsey and RJ and did this and and
I really do think and Chris we talked
about this a lot last year some
disenchantment in the organization
because of the double standard that
applied to all the players not named
Blake bortles they would make apologies
and exceptions and excuses for Blake
bortles and the rest of the team was
held to that very high standard and I
think this year that's not going to be
the case and that defense is gonna be
free to play better they're gonna feel
better about themselves and the offense
is gonna put them in better positions
they're not gonna feel like their backs
are against the wall because their
offense can't move the ball and can't
score but I can't disagree with anything
you said there I mean Jacksonville's
defense is special I mean I think you
could sit here and argue that it's more
talented maybe than the Chicago Bears
defense that we just talked about then
why didn't you pick them well I'm going
with the Bears because I think I like
their scheme a little bit more you've
heard me complain sometimes about
Jacksonville where their scheme is very
simple they kind of just say hey this is
what we do and deal with it and I
respect that
but it puts pressure on them especially
against some of the good time the really
good offenses in the game so I'm not I
mean that's a good pick by you I would a
gun I would have gone if it was role
reversal I would have dick Jacksonville
first second sounds like you would on
bears first okay my next pick I'm gonna
go with that number one defense from
last year I'm going
with the Baltimore Ravens I am I mean I
just think with some of the things they
got going on in the secondary first off
I mean Earl Thomas getting him there in
the backend to go along with Tony
Jefferson Marlin Humphrey
Jimmy Smith when he gets out there
helped Lee Brandon Carr I know they lost
CJ Mosely but there's a lot of good
linebackers on this roster to begin with
okay and the big thing with me with with
the Baltimore defense is just their
incredible size up front they are never
outmatched against any team they play
now the big question will be you know
can they get some guys that can rush the
passer off the edge you know I don't
know for sure
I'm not definitely confident in that
they have a lot of guys that I really
respect to play that outside linebacker
position you know
Tyus Bowser Pernell McPhee's gonna be
there but the big thing is I know they
have a defensive coordinator in Don wink
Martindale okay who did phenomenal last
year and he's very creative at finding
ways to stress out pass protection if
they're hurting as far as one singular
pass rusher he'll find other ways to get
after the quarterback I got to go with
that Ravens Dee yeah you look that's not
a bad choice I mean they have undergone
some transition yeah they are going to
be plugging in some new pieces and and
they need to hope that they can be
better than then then you know they
would otherwise be when you just look at
the losses versus the game yeah you know
Earl Thomas that was one of those
surprise moves that we should have seen
coming like it's the perfect team for
him to play for warfet and we didn't
realize it until the word emerge that
they had paid him a ton of money despite
that leg that was broken twice to bring
him to that team all right I'm gonna
stay in the division and I'm not going
to Pittsburgh oh the city from which the
Ravens came I think the Cleveland Browns
vastly underrated when you consider the
star potential at the two most important
levels all due respect to the
linebackers and a Chicago Bears you got
great linebackers but its defensive line
in secondary the rest of it the rest of
it can be handled Jimmy Johnson always
felt that the interior offensive line
and linebackers were replaceable the
defensive line and the secondary are the
key miles Garrett Sheldon Richardson
Olivier Vernon draw along that front
four and Denzel Ward greedy Williams
yeah and damarious Randall playing
safety morgan Burnett's still there but
denzel award was great last year needs
to be careful about the concussions
because he had a few too many last year
yeah but but he and Williams could be
great shutting down outside receivers
Garrett is ready to come into his own
you know there's been some periodic
complaints from him that Greg Williams
last year would not let him be what he
wants to be implemented the past moves
yeah and I think that defense and again
especially with a good offense yeah a
good offense is gonna make a defense
look better
yes um you know that there is a lot of
potential there I don't think I would
have picked them necessarily okay but I
mean I hear what you're saying
added to the fact that you know Mike to
all bolster your case I mean I think
Steve Wilkes being there is a great
thing too I mean Steve Wilkes hey their
defense was not bad last year in Arizona
a little bit like what you said the
offense was so crappy to put their
defense in a lot of bad spots and also
Steve Wilkes had a great track record in
Carolina before that so it's hard for me
to go against that oh now it is a
challenge it really is I don't know
where I want to go here but I'm gonna go
with a proven commodity and somebody I
trust
okay I'm going Shawn McDermott in the
Buffalo Bills Diaz yes I I am first off
I just like to remind everybody that the
Buffalo Bills were the number two rated
defense and football last year only
behind the Baltimore Ravens passing
yards per game
they led football and passed the defense
okay run defense they were middle of the
road but they got a guy like Ed Oliver
okay
on the defensive line let alone it's
guys like Jermaine Edwards or is it
Sherman I always forget him and his
brother I always mixed mixed though
Terrell Edmonds in Terrell yes which
one's in Buffalo Terrell I don't know
you're the one to pick remains there but
he's phenomenal on that side of the ball
but really the big thing I look at is
our deep defensive line okay Trent
Murphy star low to Lele Jerry Hughes is
still there Shaq Lawson's a backup
Jordan Phillips is a backup Harrison
Phillips who they like to be their new
you know Kyle Williams type of guy that
makes sense Lorenzo Alexander's their
Mike and then the secondary
might not blow you away with names
because they're not a man-to-man defense
this is where
McDermott comes into play for me
McDermott's I think one of the best game
plan schemers on a week-to-week basis in
all of football and I say this because
of this they don't play man-to-man but
man if there's three receivers to the
left
man McDermott he Scouts them out and all
the sudden seven and his guys are all
over there where the quarterback wants
to throw it he's great in playing
tendencies and figuring out offenses and
guys like Trudeau via swipe Jordan Poyer
Micah Hyde they're good players they
know how to play I'm gonna go with the
bills even though they might not be as
sexy you know it's funny when you
started to say you were going with the
proven commodity you made me nervous
that you were taking my third-round pick
that I had been sandbagging because
there is one truly proven commodity
defensively in the National Football
League and who would you say was the
best offense in the NFL last year well
the kick off the bottom well top to
bottom
oh well top to bottom I don't know the
Kansas City Chiefs came right to my mind
but who else in like this thing I'm
stroking Kansas City Chiefs in a
shootout that was supposed to be in
Mexico City
well oh the Rams yes sir how many points
did the Rams score in the Superbowl they
scored three yeah I'll take the Patriots
okay okay because here's the thing it's
Bill Belichick and he's always gonna
move those rice pieces and this Stephon
Gilmore is the only name that really
stands out and he's the one guy that
they paid market value to and I remember
when they signed him as a free agent
people like oh my god why are they
paying so much money they seen him twice
a year for five years they know a good
player when they see one when they have
to get ready to face one on a regular
basis so this is a team where Bill
Belichick is always going to take those
pieces put them in the right spot put
them in the right position come up with
the right game plan take away with the
offense does best coach his guys up take
full advantage of the rule book do
everything you possibly can do and you
know there may be some hiccups along the
way yeah statistically they may not be
great but at the end of the day winning
versus losing playoffs versus no
playoffs advancing versus not advanced
get you you know really even with the
chain load that she's scored 31 points
in the AFC Championship game but it was
it was vibe it was by unbelievable plays
by players not to scheme beating them
I'm gonna bolster your case okay thank
you name of the game with scoring points
and they don't ever let people score
points that's New England hey we go down
in Brady score seven
you go down and you score three we go
down score seven more you go down and
score three and all sudden you look up
and go man the game's even but we're
losing by eight and then it's then the
game's even but we're losing by twelve
and it just continues to go on and on
and it is the defense of game planning
and they are one of the best secondary
simple point you made about what they
did against Tyree kill yeah and coverage
underneath rise safety supposedly over
the top yeah who's constantly assigned
to double Tyree can you play the single
safety a look like it see that all year
long this year but who knows what you
see by them I know so you're taking the
coaches there with it like me with
McDermott the bills I get you I get I
thought you were taking the Patriot yeah
uh do we have a quick recap that we can
throw up when we left the Cowboys on the
table yeah we did leave the cabin the
Eagles are another D I'm looking for a
big improvement this year three rounds I
mean if we wouldn't take it so long on
round three we could have done a fourth
round you got the Bears Ravens and Bill
look at the Jaguars Browns and Patriots
I win you lose yeah that sucks for you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports